in 3 2
1 this is one of the first steps in a
trend that could upend the way movies
are made her purse was full of useless
trash AI gives Hollywood producers the
ability to capture a scan of a star and
use it to do well pretty much anything
for example neither of these guys is the
real me but the technology used to do
that comes with big risks especially for
actors so I visited the CAA Vault we'll
just step you in a studio created by one
of Hollywood's top talent agencies to
give actors control of their digital
doubles there's no way to imagine a
future world without this I don't quite
know what to anticipate here but I'm
excited to see what happens the CAA
Vault houses four different stations
that record an actor's Body Face
movements and voice I feel like Jody
Foster in contact should have sent a
poet Dominic Ridley the director of VFX
company clear angle Studios works with
CA to create these digital scans with
shooting those 17 different lighting
fires we get to see how the the light is
reacting to your materials and your skin
Etc the first step in the process is a
3d full body scan why is this the pose
so this is basically just allowing us to
capture all the inside of your arm and
hands while still being nice and relaxed
it's hard not to be a little
nervous and that's it 1 and a half
seconds that just is your full body
capture it's like a red carpet it shoots
17 different lighting environments in
just 1.2 seconds those few seconds
capture more than 200 images that look
like these later all of the images will
be used in a process called
photogrammetry which brings together
hundreds of 2D images in order to create
a 3D image of my
body the next step in the process is a
range of motion scan once it start you
start feeling that kind of tension don't
go too far past that okay like following
a workout video yeah yeah exactly it's
just like following workout video just
for all the beach scenes you're filming
me in as the technology has grown more
popular in the industry actors are
worried about their digital doubles
being used without their consent the use
of AI doubles was a major sticking point
in the recent Union negotiations between
actors and
Studios AI by I'd imagine AI is a bigger
and bigger part of your day yeah AI
became something that we as a as a
company were aware of a long time ago
Brian Lord is CEO of the creative
artists agency which represents actors
like Tom Hanks cap lanchette and Zena
and is the company behind the CIAA Vault
what we believe is that an individual
whether you're famous or not should own
your digital presence and the simple
concept of the Vault was to get out
ahead of this as the tech becomes more
accessible AI doubles could change the
way actors work for example they could
avoid hours in their trailer thanks to
digital makeup or they could use their
double for re-shoot while they move on
to another project so far there's been
little protection around how these
digital doubles are used there isn't any
federal law protecting this kind of
likeness and local laws vary from state
to state many scans are owned by Studios
Not actors and payment is also an issue
how much should an actor make when their
double is used instead of them outside
of work anyone can create their own
scans to make deep fakes that do or say
anything I'm going to show you some
magic the agency says the ca vault is
aimed at solving these issues since all
of the scans taken at the Vault belong
to the actors so that means at the end
of the day my digital identity and all
of the scans used to create it will
belong to me that includes my next one a
face scan in a machine called Dorothy
she encapsulates the highest technology
that we have at clearing the studos and
in this system we're going to capture
your face in the highest detail both for
a 3D scan we can do 4D scanning as well
do you feel like you're living in the
future um no my wife keeps me very
grounded ah yeah it captures the face in
two sessions the first for use with
photogrammetry like in the full body
scap what this does is it just allows
very very high qualities of alignment
and when you're a 3D model we can
stabilize your 3D models around the
cubes on your head each 3 second capture
grabs nearly 700 images this is followed
by a series of 76 different facial
expressions with just a single flash
that was the perfect alow Riser which is
this one really the second stage is a
capture for generative AI I which is a
series of images used by a machine
learning platform to recreate my image
in 2D this includes the full spectrum of
mouth movements so my double can say any
word and appear authentic to give the
system enough options I had to express a
lot of emotions about a beige fox that
quick beige fox jumped in the air over
each thin dog the lights Flash in very
specific patterns in this scan to
simulate different environments and then
we can replicate the lighting from the
set in here and then redo the
performance those scans come out looking
something like this allowing my double
to be placed in different environments
without the lighting looking
unnatural these days a chicken leg is a
rare dish then the last stage a scan of
my voice I could try to do like a
British accent the Hogs were fed chopped
corn and
garbage so why do you have me saying
these sentences why do we care so much
about women with trash in their purses
and and Smoky Flames these are words and
phrases that will cover every possible
sound to make other phrases or words
happen if that makes sense so from this
collection of random sounds and
sentences you can have me say or do
anything
yes CAA then stores the scans and says
they have a layer of security to protect
the data then I could hand off my
digital mask to VFX Studios like CIA
vault's partner deep Voodoo they can
then make a digital rendering of well me
while the tech is a major talking point
in Hollywood right now CIA says it's not
just actors being scanned musicians
athletes directors and content creators
have also gone through the process but
there's a lot of uncertainty about this
technology for example it's unclear how
it could impact work in Hollywood for
people who aren't major stars or what
its implications might be in politics or
our everyday lives I feel like that when
you see this technology the first
response is oh my God this is so cool
and the second response is this could
ruin the world yeah yeah does it keep
you up at night and do you worry about
that as you try to in some ways Advance
this technology yes I mean I think it
was a big fundamental question that we
had to ask ourselves is do we bury our
heads in the sand or do we Embrace this
and go after it and so we think we all
have a responsibility to embrace it but
to embrace it with some sort of ethics
and morals and and fairness in
mind